a new study by a university in London  true story has discovered that the  average IQ of humans has gone up 20  points since 1950 20 points in other  words we're all getting smarter now I  thought that was a surprising find so I  sent out a camera crew just around  Burbank to ask average Americans what  they thought about the news take a look  sir why do you think that the average IQ  of humans has gone up by 20 points since  1950 I mean it's a great question I  think you could attribute it partially  to improvement in public education in  the last 60 70 years have you heard  about this new study that says that  humans have been getting smarter and  smarter since 1950 mommy gave me to TiVo  ve humans have been getting smarter and  smarter over the last six decades excuse  me sir do you think humans are smarter  than they used to be I'm not sure but  let me ask my piece thank you this is a  roll guy I forgot okay the same guys  that took zero  kanpei  you